ma mère croit que le battement d'une
certaine classe vous donne le droit de mourir
chaque fois que vous allez bien s'il vous plaît ne le
souhaitons pas ce soir et la princesse retournant
sur les côtes étrangères de leur patrie,
ça pissait la dernière fois que j'étais
à Sydney comment pourraient-ils pas  décevoir
Dorothy Bebel mère pourquoi es-tu si en retard
tu ne te coiffes pas ma chérie
quel retour à la maison et ta belle Oh
génial ma chérie comment va la tienne une
mère - quelqu'un est là Je veux que tu sois à l'
extérieur où l'on a plus de chance
d'être frappé par un coup de foudre  maintenant une
grande orbite
je souhaite ces debuffs mon état
à la danseuse allemande allez Dorothy
tu ne peux pas voir nos mères complètement
Gaga tu penses que je ne sais pas pourquoi tu as
volé partout sur la terre je pensais que je
pourrais passer la nuit ma chambre est
vous traversez à nouveau une période difficile
Dorothy, je pense que nous pouvons voir que l'on est
passé au pigeon de passage non converti
votre père visiteur dans le pays et
s'il vous plaît ne revenez pas avant que la tempête ne
soit terminée films trop géniaux 2 4  6 8 brumeux
et dope
je ne peux pas vraiment me permettre d'énerver ma
mère en ce moment pourquoi serait-elle
énervée elle m'aime les autres
oh rien ne
te bénisse chérie - la générosité les parents
finissent tout d'un coup
Oh
toi